we're told that jada owns a restaurant
where customers can make their orders
using an app
she decides to offer a discount on
appetizers to attract more customers
and she's curious about the probability
that a customer orders a large
number of appetizers jada tracked
how many appetizers were in each of the
past 500 orders
all right so the number of appetizers so
40 out of the 500
ordered zero appetizers and for example
120
out of the 500 ordered three appetizers
and so on and so forth
let x represent the number of appetizers
in a random order
based on these results construct an
approximate probability distribution
of x pause this video and see if you can
have a go at this before we do this
together
all right so they're telling us an
approximate
probability distribution because we
don't know the
actual probability we can't get into
people's minds and figure out the
probability that the neurons fire in
exactly the right way
to order appetizers but what we can do
is look at
past results empirical data right over
here
to approximate the distribution so we
can do is
look at the last 500 and for each of the
outcomes think about what fraction of
the last 500 had that outcome and that
will be our approximation
and so the outcomes here we could have
zero appetizers one
two three four five or
six now the approximate probability of
zero appetizers is going to be
40 over 500 which is the same thing
as 4 over 50 which is the same thing
as 2 over 25 so i'll write 2
20 fifths right over there the
probability of one appetizer
well that's going to be 90 over 500
which is the same thing
as 9 over 50. i think that's already in
lowest terms then 160
over 500 is the same thing as 16
over 50 which is the same thing as 8
over 25 and we just keep going
120 out of 500 is the same thing as 12
out of 50 or 6 out of 25
6 out of 25
and then 50 out of 500 well that's one
out of every 10
so i'll just write it like that 30 out
of 500
is the same thing as 3 out of
50. so i'll just write it like that
and that last but not least 10 out of
500 is the same thing as
1 in 50. and we're done
we have just constructed an approximate
probability distribution
for our random variable x